we've been showing you those images of
partiers on spring break down in Florida
ignoring the warnings to socially
distance from one another
yeah there's at least 20 people in that
picture but now it seems the party may
be over as bars and restaurants are
closed and some cities have decided to
close their beaches Florida Governor Ron
de Santos joins us right now from
Tallahassee governor good morning good
morning
well those images are disturbing because
the CDC says no groups have more than 10
and then you see that stuff and so I
understand Clearwater Beach and Naples
have decided to close their beaches to
two groups but at the same time you're
not closing the state beaches two groups
of less than ten right so the message I
think for Spring Breakers is that the
party's over in Florida where you're not
going to be able to congregate on any
Beach in the state many of the hot spots
that people like to go to whether it's
Miami Beach Fort Lauderdale Clearwater
Beach are closed entirely for the time
being the bars are closed so you're not
going to have a place to congregate
there so we would just tell those folks
you know maybe come back next year when
things are better but that is not what
we're looking for here in the state of
Florida every single Beach will have to
abide by the CDC guidelines no more than
ten people you have to be socially
distant not every beach is going to
remain open but but some will we have
sheriff's deputies in places like
Brevard County you know they're out
gonna be out on ATVs making sure there's
no groups and I think that that's a
that's a good approach I would point out
though guys you know the images from
Clearwater was on from the Saturday at
that point the CDC guidance was groups
of 250 or more then on Sunday they
changed it to 50 and so we were working
with locals to try to figure out okay
what would make sense for us on a whole
variety of things and then the next day
on Monday they changed it to the 10 and
so that's at that point we're like okay
well we just need to steer clear of any
large groups so we did it for the
beaches and then we did it for for the
bars and close the bars down so and I
also would say this we're seeing
massive cancellations going forward I
think some of those pictures were for
people who had started coming down here
before this got to the level that it did
and so I think a lot of this stuff
you're gonna see a lot fewer people
coming into Florida right now the
numbers are really off the charts in
terms of the cancellations governor I'm
so glad you came on to explain that
because I was gonna ask you what do you
say to the critics that say this should
have been done a lot sooner but Saturday
was a totally different story than it is
here Thursday we you know many of us
were planning different events the
beginning of the week and all of those
were canceled what do you say I was
reading a story that clear waters not
closing its beaches though until Monday
right well so the you know they got to
make the decisions as how they see it
but regardless of those local decisions
you're not going to be able to
congregate like those images that you
saw that's just not something that we're
going to allow and so you know we want
to work constructively with the locals
to get the best solutions but I would
also say when you have these types of
cancellations you know that's gonna have
a major effect on a lot of workers in
the state of Florida our unemployment
rate prior to this got down to 2.8
percent I mean just where our economy
was humming things were going along
great and now this external event this
virus is gonna dislocate a lot of people
and so you know we're very mindful of
that and we're working hard to be able
to work with them just as we work to be
able to protect our citizens from from
the virus sure governor when you talk to
the president in the White House team
what do you tell them your main concern
is for us it's just supplies I mean
we've ramped up testing but I need more
swabs I need more of the reagents if we
have that we could dramatically expand
the testing and I think that will really
help us because part of the problem with
some of the stuff that we've been doing
and I and I don't know quarrel with it
but it's not really based on data in our
country it's more based on modeling when
you get the more tests in there like
South Korea did you're able to isolate
those cases figure out where the
problems are and then have a nice
targeted solution to it so that is
really the number one thing the PPE the
swabs the different things that go into
these things the more we can get of
those you know we really can get into a
good groove here and I think we'll be
able to put to to help a lot of people
and prevent this virus from spreading to
the extent it has all right you have a
lot of snow birds that live there that I
guess are gonna stay there in Florida
and not come back up here to New York
but a lot of our friends cancel their
trips to the Bahamas or where you know
or to Europe or whatever and they all
ended up in Florida so I hope they
didn't carry it down there god bless you
thank you so much couple people are
being there they're being very mindful a
lot of folks are really taking this
seriously and we thank them particularly
our senior citizens yeah it's all about
personal responsibility sir thank you
very much good luck